good morning believe nation today's
message is don't shy away from the
challenge our to you mark wahlberg
playing a professor in college it was a
bit of a stretch but something that I
was excited about I'm never one who
really shied away from a challenge I
usually kind of jump at the opportunity
to do something different and unexpected
but I'm also the kind of guy who's going
to make sure that I'm prepared you know
really cover all the bases and you know
I don't want to to look foolish and I
don't certainly don't want to disappoint
so what do you think I think that was an
awesome story um I personally can relate
to not shying away from the challenges
in my life and one of the biggest one
was when I graduated from university I
really wanted to go to Europe and work
in Europe people told me that it's
really difficult to find a job all the
way to Europe you shouldn't do it you
should instead go on you know work for a
bank or do something else so eventually
I did end up in Europe I lived in
Belgium for over a year and I work for a
vodka bank it was an amazing experience
living in Europe experiencing the
culture and I was super excited that I
was actually able to do something that I
really wanted to do when everyone told
me don't do it it's waste of time you're
just going to you know nothing's gonna
happen you're just gonna spend your time
on applying for role but it's not gonna
happen what I accomplished through not
trying away from a challenge was when I
came back to Canada everyone thought
that oh it was so cool that you worked
in Belgium in diamond industry and you
were doing anti-money laundering
compliance that right away I got a lot
of offers for jobs and I ended up in a
really great company that I love working
for and I have a great role with the
company so I think the lesson learned
here is that
if you shy away from the challenges in
life you're not going to experience the
greatest things that you've always
wanted and that could get you to the
next level so take risk and don't shy
away from the challenges I love the
message I think we're gonna always have
these moments in our lives when an
opportunity comes that we're not quite
ready for yet and that's when it's easy
to say no I'm not ready I don't the
experience I don't the confidence I have
the courage and you have all these
limiting self beliefs that come into
play and you tell you stuff all the
reasons why you can't go and do
something and those are the changes that
you have the opportunity to step up and
kind of rise to the next level right
because there's always these new
opportunities coming at you I think even
Rosanna
looking at her coming on today it wasn't
supposed to be Rosanna here with me
today was posed to be her boyfriend Alex
who helps me run this studio eternal day
and salsa
he's sick puking and just lying down in
bed and I said Rosanna why don't you
come out today and help me with the
videos and she's never been on our
YouTube channel before and was nervous
and scared but said I'm gonna do it and
so it's not about not being nervous not
being scared but it's about feeling it
absorbing it and still doing it anyway
because it's through those moments that
you can have significant growth I think
about you and Alex too in terms of
teaching opportunities here at TDS we
had this crisis we had this moment where
like okay you could teach today but it's
got to be today it's an emergency you
can go you may not be ready yet do you
want to do it and to their credit both
Alex and Rosanna both said I'm scared
but yes we're gonna do it and so you
know you're gonna have those moments in
your life where you will get an
opportunity that is beyond you and this
is your chance to grow and for you to
say I'm scared but let's do it so the
question of a today is what challenges
are there in your life today and what
can you do about them I like it leave it
in the comments below we'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
Phoebe go